el agua sorprendió en medio de la noche
y arrasó con todo en la comunidad de
santa teresa en el departamento de
carazo al sur de nicaragua la tormenta y
otra dejó su rastro con intensas lluvias
que provocaron la crecida del río a la
piñuela esa subida causó la muerte de
cinco personas de una misma familia que
fueron afectados mientras dormían
este a mi hermana y a cuatro sobrinas
vino la crecida de ríos un solo impacto
que no supimos cuando lo que hicimos
safarián no teníamos parentesco
recortamos entre medio de los ríos y se
unieron un solo impulso nos dio tiempo
de salir nada nada nada
se va llevando al padre todo menos entre
los lugareños existe la convicción de
que nunca se había presentado una
situación así el desborde del río
destruyó las viviendas de siete familias
y otras diez sufrieron daños parciales
aunque la vicepresidenta rosario murillo
dijo que era cinco víctimas les oyeron
las recomendaciones de evacuar los
habitantes aseguran que no hubo alertas
no obstante admiten que confiaron en que
no sufrirían el impacto del huracán yo
está tal como había sucedido semanas
atrás con eta en las noticias decían del
huracán
pero usted sabe que a veces dicen y no
sucede entonces uno se confía hasta el
momento los habitantes de esta comunidad
no han podido acceder a la ayuda
humanitaria del gobierno y denuncian que
nadie se ha presentado a ofrecerles
asistencia